[Music]
what are you doing here in Somerville
anyway honestly my mom wants it but
we're completely broke and the only
thing that's left in our name this is
creepy old farmhouse my grandfather left
us in the middle of nowhere why'd you
bring me up here entertainment value
what is that
[Music]
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fall lines
no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily basis
I remember that one summer he died on
our table I found this in my living room
Oh killer replica a replica of what a
ghost trap there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30 years New York in the
eighties it's like The Walking Dead your
dad never mentioned this to you it's
just my mom my grandfather died my mom
says we're just here to pick through the
Rob loves life
when
who are you
call it fake
[Music]
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
[Music]
I believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a Connor seats
[Music]